If this difference increases then that means that the whole t statistic will
increase. If x increases that means that the denominator is increasing and then
that will cause t to decrease. A larger n will result in a smaller standard
error, in other words a decreased denominator. And that means that the
t-statistic will increase. And if the whole standard error increases, then that
means the t-statistic will decrease. Going backwards the larger the
t-statistic, the higher it is on the t-distribution and the lower the
probability of obtaining that t-statistic. And then the larger the difference
between means that we would expect. This same concept applies to negative t
statistics.